Hi there and welcome to ESaaS Managing Distributed teams and the question on everyone's lips,
or at least on the lips of this slide, if it has lips, is what is this course about?
So this course is about a number of things.
Perhaps first and foremost it's about learning how to manage distributed teams;
that's teams of people working, where team members are in a number of different locations.
We're thinking particularly about teams working online in different places around the world.
However we have some other agenda items in terms of delivering this course.
The skills of managing distributed teams are going be very useful for anybody who wants
to be a teaching assistant (or TA) in the BerkeleyX computer science 169 course which
is a very popular online course for software engineering and Agile development using Ruby
on Rails.
Already many thousands of students around the world have completed this course and we're
looking for people to be teaching assistants, which as well as solidifying your software
engineering skills is a great way to practice your distributed team management skills.
We're also hoping to prepare you to collaborate on Open Source projects.
Particularly those with AgileVentures and more on each of these three things as we move
forward
Lets go to the next slide which is all about distributed teams;
so the traditional office environment you have people in a room or a couple of rooms
or maybe on a few different floors of an office;
and that's how people have worked for quite a long time.
Of course there's phones and more recently instant messaging systems which have invaded
the office,
but the big difference now is the presence of high quality video networking tools that
are freely available such as Skype, Zoom and Google hangouts.
These tools make it possible for people in multiple locations around the world to operate
almost as if they are in the same physical location.
We're getting more and more new tools and technologies to help with communication and
collaboration around the world and in this course we'll give you an overview of the different
tools and technologies that are being used;
as well as how you can get the best use of them in order to support your own distributed
teams;
to work with teams of students online;
to work on open source projects and so on.
The thing the we want to emphasize is for any of these tools, and also for technologies
like the individual programming languages and so on, that these things will come and
go.
The specific tools and technologies are critical to focus on because without them we can't
get specific about how we do things now.
However, underlying everything else are these key aspects of communication and collaboration
... in 5-10 years time maybe there's going to be a different set of tools, a different
set of programming languages and frameworks around, but the interpersonal skills that
you need to manage and work with people;
those are eternal and those are ultimately the critical things to take away from from
this course.
So that said we do have this upcoming worldwide course and many thousands of students will
be coming online and taking BerkeleyX's very successful software engineering course, now
called "Agile Development using Ruby on Rails" .
Already 10s of thousands of students have taken this course in order to be introduced
to tools like Pivotal Tracker, Heroku, Github and to get to grips with Ruby on Rails and
Agile development.
This is a very very popular course that goes through all these modern software engineering
techniques and tools and it's particularly focused on Ruby on Rails and in order to help
those many thousands of students we need teaching assistants;
people who are available to be online and help those students as they master all this
new material.
We'll talk more soon about just how valuable and rewarding it is to be a Teaching Assistant.
To finish up this section let's talk about Open Source projects.
So our other motive here is we believe strongly in Open Source, where you can see all the
code in a software system.
This is a great thing for collaboration because anyone can get involved in fixing things or
adding features.
We particularly believe in Open Source for non-profit projects but there's Open Source
used by for-profit ventures around the world and of course you don't need to talk to us
in order to know how to get involved in Open Source.
There are many existing Open Source projects, however the collaboration in many of those
projects will be text based and asynchronous.
Given the great stellar consolation of different Open Source projects that are out there you
might ask yourself which one do I get involved in, who do I talk to about what's going on?
This is exactly what we've set up Agile Ventures to help with.
It's an Open Source project incubator which helps people get together to work on Open
Source projects both asynchronously and synchronously through Remote pair programming and online
scrums through systems like Google hangouts.
It's all free and open and the greatest benefit is that you can see the Agile development
process for real.
Participating in an Agile Ventures project is a great way to see how the Agile development
process works in the distributed environment.
To summarize in this course you'll learn a lot about the process of managing distributed
teams benefiting from our experience of the last several years of working with the students
and TA's in the online CS169 course and the various ongoing AgileVentures projects.
Those Open Source projects have been and continue to be a huge lot of fun and I very much hope
you'll enjoy the rest this course, as we learn about distributed teams in the context of
managing online classes and open source projects. Alright, bye for now.